puissant 1 780 habitants sur la route
des grands crus madame le maire boucle
les derniers dossiers avant de passer la
main geneviève pelletier ne se
représente pas après huit ans aux
commandes du village elle estime qu'elle
a fait son temps même chose pour ses
quatre adjoints et jusqu'à ce week-end
elle a bien cru qu'il n'y aurait pas de
candidat à la succession aujourd'hui à
les rassurer en partie je m'interroge un
petit peu sur les manques de
d'entousiasme ou le manque de motivation
pour la fonction municipale et c'est un
peu inquiétant pour une commune qui à
près de 800 habitants d'avoir autant de
mal à trouver des candidats
désormais la liste est presque complète
14 candidats pour 15 sièges à pourvoir
au conseil municipal c'est quand même
suffisant parmi les candidats gilbert
rigaud depuis le mois de novembre avec
trois autres membres de l'équipe
municipale sortante ce retraité a
cherché des volontaires courrier
individuel réunion et même porte-à-porte
convaincre ses concitoyens de s'engager
a été très difficile
parce que on favorise plus les loisirs
au bénévolat pas ce que c'est c'est du
temps consacré dix ans notre village la
population
on les gens retraités il ya beaucoup de
retraités qui n'ont pas le temps ca c on
entend souvent
dossier sous le bras gilbert ego peut-on
s'en aller à la préfecture pour déposer
officiellement les quatorze candidatures
mais mardi matin en côte d'or une
soixantaine de villages de moins de 1000
habitants n'avait encore aucun candidat
déclaré jeudi à 18 heures ce sera trop
tard pour le premier tour mais pas pour
le second
il ya une petite subtilité c'est à dire
que même si pour le premier tour il n'y
avait pas de candidature il pourrait y
en avoir entre le premier et le second
tour et à ce moment là il pourrait
malgré tout y avoir une élection au
second tour faute de candidats en
revanche au premier et au second tour
pas d'élection c'est la préfecture qui
se chargera de gérer la commune